when we look at Iran funding people in
the region I don't disagree with that as
well I think Iran is the number one
instigator of bad guy things right now
in the Middle East Iran um the irgc I
supported when Donald Trump killed
sumani I think that was a great thing um
I I think that Iran is a major problem
however I don't know if the path forward
is constantly being a belligerent to
Iran or trying to figure out some road
to normaly I don't know if the collapse
of Iran um or the destruction of that
country considering how unpopular the
AOL even is there like the citizens of
Iran I don't think are big supporters of
the government there um I I feel like
moving on a path where you know let's do
our nuclear inspections we had that um
Iranian nuclear deal that Trump pulled
out of let's do the nuclear inspections
make sure you're not on the way to
nuclear weapons let's unfree some funds
let's move in some Direction Where We
Get on a good term with you I feel like
that's the most important thing that
needs to happen in the Middle East as
much as people like to look at the
Abraham Accords who cares if what what
was it uh Bahrain I think Oman um I
think the UAE and Morocco yeah are like
all of these people even Saudi Aria
already have like de facto normalization
with Israel anyway they're all trading
this I mean to to pretend that that
anybody even 15 years ago would have
been talking about normalization between
Saudi Arabia and Israel is insane they
already they were already on that path
they had already been tra they were
already de facto trading partners with
each other that that they had already
been collaborating and do that's a wild
claim that that Israel and Saudi Arabia
were going to normalize 15 years ago 15
years ago might have been a wild clent
but after Turkey um after Jordan and
then in the past like 20 years of like
economic relations and ties with each
other all of the leadership in the
Middle East and you'll agree with this
look at Israel and they go okay well
we've got Palestinians who you know God
bless them do nothing and then you've
got Israel which is uh on a on a region
with no natural resources to somehow
become like an economic giant they're
good at trade with their population is
educated they you know have military
power um all of the leadership in these
Middle Eastern countries are wanting to
be friendly with Israel and are engaging
in trade de facto with Israel and the
idea that like the UAE and bahin were
brought in to say like oh well now we're
going to officially say this I I I just
those those are the first steps toward
obviously the formation of a new Middle
East in which economics would
predominate over sectarian conflict the
chief obstacle to that is Iran the
notion that you that that negotiations
with the Ayatollah were going to be a
solution to any of this is do think
absolutely are the is it the Abraham
Accords that's convincing Saudi Arabia
to take a stance against Iran no I mean
Saab already fighting yeah they're
already fighting with each other right I
don't think the abrs moved us any closer
towards any type of real peace in
has to happen is something has to happen
with Iran there has to be some
diplomatic bilateral communication there
no what has to happen is the containment
of Iran which was what was in which was
what was taking place with the increased
normalization with the Sunni Arab world
and Israel combined with significant
economic
sanctions the notion that that there's
this far-fetched notion in in foreign
policy circles that diplomacy can sort
of be wish cast out of thin air that if
you sit around a table that you can
always come to an agreement with
somebody the Ayatollah do not have
common interests with the United States
they they do not and this idea that they
are willing to take money in exchange
for for example some sort of PE peaceful
acquiescence to Israel's existence is
obviously untrue historically hasn't
that been the case though that you've
had a region with tons of sectarian
violence for a long time and then
finally turkey was like you know what
this isn't worth it the United States
paid him a lot of money they had
conversations with Israel you know what
the the economy the economic gains same
with Jordan same with into Turkish
politics but the but but the the
situation with turkey was actually quite
warm between Israel and Turkey in the
90s when you had the the you know sort
of secular Muslim
regime Turk in place and and now erdan
is has joined in the frey and erdan is
significantly more radical than I'm so
sorry um if I said tur Egypt my bad yeah
Egypt yeah right yeah so in terms of
like Egypt and Jordan right were the
first two you need so here's the thing
you need is it possible that you could
theoretically come to a deal with Iran
only with a new leadership crew okay
this is true for every peace agreement
in the region you you could not Israel
could not have made peace with well they
made peace with Egypt and Sadat was the
leader for Yom kapor right he did not
make peace with Nasser right the point
is that this is a different regime you
need a different regime this think the
same regime that did the part of the Yum
kapore war was the same regime that
negotiated peace with Israel I mean
that's true it is also true that that is
a relationship that could be cultivated
specifically because it was sadad who
made clear he was going to come to the
table mhm have the Iranians ever made
clear that they would come to the table
over for example the existence of the
state of Israel uh no that is not a
thing that's going to happen but I think
every every single one of their proxy
group every one of them not only calls
for the destruction of the state of
Israel they also call for the
destruction of America I mean this is
literally the houthi slogan they're busy
hitting ships and their slogan is
literally ALU Akbar death to America
death to the Jews death to Israel it
doesn't fit on a bumper sticker but that
and it's not all that catchy but that is
in fact their slogan the notion that the
regime that propagat that is going to be
approach with diplomacy is not only
wrong the problem is that it's easy to
say the stakes of diplomacy are okay so
we try to talk right jaw jaw is better
than war war sure the only problem is
that in the Middle East weakness is
taken as a sign that aggression might be
an appropriate response that is how
things work in the Middle East and the
fact that baraco that that Joe Biden
rather came into office with an
orientation toward continuing the Biden
the the Obama policy in Iran has led to
conflagrations these sort of brush fires
breaking out everywhere that Iran has
borders with either the west or Israel
or both right any place that's happening
is leading to brushfires because again
the logic of violence in the Middle East
is not quite the logic of violence in
other places in the world by the way I
think the logic of vins in the Mast is
actually closer to what most
International politics looks like than
we than we wish that it were I mean I
think that's part of what's happening in
Ukraine as well think which brings me by
the way here's my question about Ukraine
just real quick you so you think that
for Iran right a country that has been
sanctioned for God knows how many years
now you think that for Iran just
continuing to sanction them and contain
them is an effective way is more
effective than trying to engage them in
bilateral or multilateral peace talks
yes 100% And the proof is in the
pudding